Hey ! On est reparti pour une petite visite ou quoi ?!
Les amis , nous sommes de retour sur " Player BattleGround " ( nom du jeu )
Ce jeu qui me rend si addict et sur lequel je me débrouille
De temps à autre
Alors , je vais vous faire visiter ces terres..
Deja battue par des centaines de milliers de personne avant moi..
Ces sentiers battues  du plus éloignée au plus proche de nos contrées..
Messieurs dame bienvenue dans ce deuxieme épisode de..
La visite du guide Squeezie , est-ce qu'il est fort au jeux vidéo ?!
Alors ! Pour commencer bien sûr la base de tout les issues de secours sont situés
A l'avant ! Et aux cotés ! Et derrière l'appareil ! Ok?!
Maintenant c'est ti-par on va casser des culs !
Mec , on va allez a Gatka bien sur !!
Contrés éloigné de la province charnoinaise !
As-tu connu ?! La province charnoinaise !
Y a un mec qui est descendu avec moi
Ok ,  on va aller dans ces petits pâtés de maison là
On va pas être tout de suite dans une grosse ville
Parceque finalement heuu , le battleground , c'est pas que Poutchinky ou Rozok
Tout comme le Japon , y'a pas que Tokyo !
Alors je vais vous faire visiter d'abord tout ce qui est un petit peu rural
Hein , la ou ça vote Le Pen et que c'est bien bien raciste
[Rires]
Excusez moi
Oh ! y'a un mec ! Il vote Le Pen !
Personne ne votera Le Pen dans cette vidéo mon pote , tu va te faire enculer !
Allez faut qu'on trouve une arme avant lui , le premier qui trouve.. J'ai gagné
J'ai gagné , il est où ?
Personne ne votera aujourd'hui !
Voila , ça m'a fait du bien  , Bon
Alors..Ah ! Y'a des bruits
Il est rentré..
Surprise Motherfucker !
Où est ta carte électorale ?! Hein ?!
C'est pas un bureau de vote ici !
Pardon , j'suis dechainé mais la ça fait du bien
Alors , encore un ? Il a une arme.
Tu fait quoi avec ton pied de biche putain ! Mais c'est pas vrai !
J'me suis mis archi bien sur ce début de game
Alors ! Alors ! Bon , finissons de fouiller ce bureau de vote finalement [rire]
Un peu vide , désormais , les présidentielles c'est fini !
Hein !  Donc ça dégage !
Bon du coup ils ont fouillées les alentours  y'avait rien
Nan mais c'est pas possible , y'avait forcement quelque chose à un endroit..
Pourquoi ils sont tous venus me voir alors qu'ils ont pas même pas fouillé aux alentours
Regarde ! Là y'avait un fusil à pompe,  mais ils sont cons
Voilà le but les amis ! Ça va être de se stuff à mort avant de rejoindre les grandes villes
Finalement , de faire l'exode heuuu rural
Ouais ! Des fois j'ai des petits souvenirs du collège qui reviennent ! Ouais ! [Rires]
Y'a un mec , on va lui dire bonjour ou pas ?
Il s'est gouré putain !
Le mec il a pas vue que le bureau de vote c'était là-bas !
Bon ! On va aller lui rendre visite !
Aaah.. Va falloir lui tirer les vers du nez à celui la , il est où ?!
Montre toi c'est pas le bureau de vote  mon gars !
Ici une situation très commune
A ce village... de l'A...d'Alsace
C'est quand...
(Musique de James Bond )
Voila ! Quand aucun des deux  n'ose dire bonjour à l'autre !
Arrêtez d'être timide dans ce village
Putain , ils ont pas l'habitude de voir des gens !
On va tout lui prendre...Bien sur
Car nous sommes.. Des bandits  tout à fait !
Bon bah les amis  , on a maintenant désingué, les 4 habitants de ce village d'Alsace
On les a vus dans les campagnes , allons les voir dans des villes !
"Héééé ils sont lààà.."
Alors on va se diriger vers vers * a répétition* .... Ici !
C'est parti
Y'avait quelqu'un  par ici mon ami !
Mais où te cache tu ? Mon ami je sait que t'étais ici ! Montre toi !
Bon y'a personne en fait
Le village voisin au village de Charontol bien sur !
C'est le visage de Charontoune !
On y'arrive je crois qu'il y'a personne ici
Alors on va allez vers ... LA-BAS
J'espère juste qu'on va pas   se prendre une balle de sniper
On est jamais à l'abris !
Ici , champ de blé bien sûr
Par ce qu'il faut savoir  que le visage de Charentone et de Charontour
J'sais plus ce que j'avais dit merde !
Vivent essentiellement de l'agriculture
C'est pour ça qu'on y retrouve pas mal de champs
Hein , comme celui nous sommes actuellement
Bonjour , nous venons en paix !
On va pas voler le tracteur , vous en faites pas !
Ouiiii ! Ah oui c'est un très grand oui !
Nous venons de ramasser un sniper !
Chuut
Ils sont partout , "Dans les campa... " , pas un bruit !
Ca c'est les guises conquérents qui m'a voler la moitié de mes clients sur 1 an
On arrive , On arrive , On arrive ! On est là !
Il sait qu'on est là...
Sinon il sortirait ...
Il sait qu'il a fait du bruit et qu'il a attirer LE vrai guide de ces lieux
Ah on l'a vu ! Regardez ! Il est la baaaas !
Juste la juste la..
JE SUIS LE VRAI GUIDE !
TU EST LE FAUX GUIDE !
Qui me vole mes clients !
En les faisant payer 1 euro moins cher le ticket !
Tain , mais en fait je fait le malin
Mais quand j'abandonne mon perso deux secondes
J'me rend compte que j'suis en stress à mort , je tremble quoi .. [souffle]
Regardez-le lui là-bas
Et voila ! Mais qu'est ce que tu viens ![rire]
J'ai même pu d'vanne , j'tue trop de gens par rapport aux nombre de vannes que j'arrive à développer
C'est terrible
On va pouvoir prendre le véhicule , de manière à s'extirper de là...
On va se diriger vers Pochinki la grande ville ! C'est parti !
Là ce qu'on va faire c'est vraiment camper aux extrémités du champ de force
C'est comme qu'il faut faire pour...gagner en fait!
Oh Y a des tirs attention !
Ca viens de loin ça... comme La Fouine !
"Je viens de loin"
On y va à pieds le Buggy c'est trop grillé ça fait trop de bruits faudrait un moteur électrique y en a pas...
Rejoignons la zone !
Le blème c'est que là on va se retrouver face a des gens qui campent dans les bâtiments comme
"Les pire FDP de l'histoire de la planète !"
mais j'ai un plan B
S'il nous tire dessus, on saute dans l'eau et on va sous l'eau !
Quand tu es sous l'eau tu es invincible dans ce jeu.
Ne me demander pas pourquoi !
Ce n'est pas moi qui l'es fait.
Il y a un mec au-dessus. Je vous le dit je l'es entendu.
Je pense qu'il y a un mec sur le toit. Non ?!
Bon ! Le guide est perdu les amis c'est l'une des rares fois où le guide est perdu et qu'il ne sait pas quoi faire!
Ok, le champ de force arrive, il faut y aller !
Si un mec me tire dessus pendant que je fuis le champ de force c'est INJUSTE !
Dès qu'on aura passé la montagne ça ira mieux mais la…
Haaaa!!!!
HAAA !!! (cri strident)
(ALARME)
(Clappement de main)
ET VOILA !
Ok! Il y a bien quelqu'un sur le toit qui campais et qui attendais
BRAVOOOOO!!
Le guide a presque envie de prendre sa retraite! Mais alors vraiment!
Ce n'est pas vrais on y retourne. Motivé!
Messieurs dames, bienvenue dans la province de Gatka.
Un espace agréable
Plein de verdure et de PLATS !
Il n'y a rien aux alentour.
Tes courses tu te démerde pour les faire. Mais bon !
C'est une ville qui vit du tourisme, qui vit donc grâce à vous ! Qui regardez la vidéo car vous etez les touristes dans cette vidéo.
Et je suis le guide !
Ça c'est fait ! Aller on en parle plus.
(Chansonnette)
Bon la clairement, on est entre tous les bâtiments
Si c'est la fête des voisins, mon pote, on est morts. Clairement.
Et !! Mais c'est là où on c'était régaler tout à l'heure.
Alors ! Toujours la petite poêle, sa protège le derrière. Regarder !
Ça ! Sa empêchera les balles d'attendre votre coccyx.
C'est très bien ! Et ce n'est pas une blague en plus, c'est la vérité !
Ha je savais qu'il y avait un mec, je l'avais entendu !
En plus, il n'a pas l'air de vouloir se joindre à la visite.
Vous l'avez vue ?
NOUS on l'avez vu !!!
HA! HA!
Il m'a mis mal !
Le mec il était à sa fenêtre depuis 20minute quoi !
Ouai ! Tu ne me la feras pas!
On sait très bien que tu n'étais pas avec un verre de rosé entrain de maté la nature!
Espèce de mytho vas !
T'es entrain de mater le cul du guide pour lui mettre une balle dedans!
C'est tout ce que tu étais en train de faire!
Ah monsieur le campeur. Qu'est-ce que vous avez pour moi ?
Ha, ben une petit SCAR-L et ben il nous manquait ça tien.
Bon ben excellent ça ! Merci mon ami.
Bon ben les amis, on doit se diriger vers une prochaine zone qui est ???
à Potchinky, à quelque pas d'ici
C'est une ville qu'on n'a pas encore visité
Ça me rend heureux voilà.
J'ai le smile
Oh là là ! La si on se fait tirer dessus c'est comme tout à l'heure
On est les gens les plus vulnérables d'Europe
Et c'est fini !
Mais on a la poêle qui protège nos fesses! Regarder, on la voit bien!
Les amis nous arrivons à Potchinki et sa merveilleuse cathédrale juste ici !
Classée, patrimoine historique bien sûr.
Ben voilà c'est une petite ville sympa Heuuu...
Dans laquelle normalement tu y vas dès le début quand tu as des couilles !
Mais ce n'est pas mon cas.
Hennin!
La prochaine zone est tellement loin.
Faut y aller faut qu'on court dès maintenant! On n'a pas le temps!
Aller ! Aller ! Ne stressez pas suivez le guide tous vas bien se passer, ne vous en fait pas !
En plus le guide le guide et totalement serin comme vous pouvez le voir!
Il n'y a vraiment pas de quoi avoir peur !
(OUIIINN !)   J'ai peur !
Ho il y a une voiture ! YES !
Je suis sûr que le mec la mise la et il campe a un endroit et il attend que quelqu'un monte dedans!
FONCE ! Putain la Dacia de merde.
Oui mais les tarifs sont tellement bas que je n'ai pas de quoi m'acheter une meilleur caisse putain !
Aller ! Haaaaaaaaa! La Dacia c'est l'accident !
Tout va bien ! Tout va bien !
Putain de Dacia !
Je vous annonce qu'on est parmi les 19 survivants de cette visite.
Tuer vous! Tuer vous! Hein ! Moi j'entretien mes visiteurs.
Quelqu'un veut un petit bonbon ? Quelqu'un ? dit-moi hein ? Moi je vous mets bien.
La prochaine fois que ça se rétréci, il n'y aura plus de bâtiment.
Sa vas être une Battle à base de gens cacher derrière des arbres.
Le guide est sous pression !
Han !
Ça court de partout !
La lumière arrêtée !
Tuez-vous tous ! Moi je cours au dernier moment comme un lâche.
Faut y aller là.
Fils de pu** de campeur quoi !
Wow Wow Wow
T'es sur de toi ?
YEEEEEEEEEEEEEES !!!
Trousse de secours
Il m'a fait peur.....Il m'a fait peur
Là mec! Il y a pas plus collé à la zone que nous!
On peut le faire les amis ! On peut le faire !
On peut gagner ! On est plus que 5
Est-ce que le guide va gagner ???
Je pleure
Je ne pleure pas parce que je vous ai déçu, je pleure parce que j'ai frôlé la crise cardiaque
Ha ha ha ha
Ho putain mec
Et voilà les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette visite guidée
J'espère qu'elle vous a plus. Si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à mettre 5 sur 5 sur tripadvisoooor !
C'était hyper drôle. C'était la dernière vidéo que je faisais sur ce jeu.
J'avais envie d'en faire une parce que la dernière fois ça vous avait bien plu et ca m'avais bien plu aussi
Ce jeu me met la pression mec c'est un truc de malade comment il met la pression c'est terrible. C'est astronomique !
On a fini 5ème, on peut être fier de nous, bravo et puis
Ha ba c'est fini au revoir
*Générique de fin*